[Musique]
bonjour François Bayrou bonjour Emmanuel
Macron va s'adresser aux Français ce
soir pour tenter de relancer son
quinquennat mais est-ce qu'il en a
encore les moyens
le président de la République a tous les
moyens de s'exprimer et le pays à tous
les moyens de rebondir le
on vient de vivre un acte naturellement
très important une crise pas facile pour
une crise ou quoi on a connu ça après
chaque réforme des retraites quasiment
sans exception je si je remonte dans ma
mémoire j'arrive
dit quand il a lancé la première réforme
des retraites il avait dit il y a de
quoi faire tomber 30 gouvernements 20 ou
30 gouvernements et donc tout ça est
classique mais c'est évident que ça pèse
sur l'ambiance du pays et ça sert à rien
de dire le contraire on est donc on est
dans une
mode dans un moment de de reconstruction
de relance
publique et du
j'allais dire du moral du pays vous
allez le voir tout à l'heure avec les
cas de la majorité quelques heures avant
son allocution est-ce que vous allez lui
dire plutôt fonce t'as plus rien à
perdre ou arrondi les angles maintenant
je ne tutoie vous n'avez plus rien à
perdre ou arrondissant les gens c'est de
ces deux affirmations pérempentoires ne
me ressemblent pas
la situation elle est évidente pour tout
le monde
la France est un grand pays qui aurait
beaucoup d'atouts et qui se trouve
paralysé dans une partie importante de
son activité il y a quelque chose de qui
pèse sur le moral du pays et un certain
nombre de sujets que nous n'arrivons pas
à traiter depuis des décennies c'est ça
la situation
est-ce que le Président de la République
peut dire on s'arrête c'est ridicule il
a il a été élu précisément pour rendre
pays cette volonté d'avancer
qui qui lui manque tant et face à Marine
Le Pen au second tour
on est toujours élu au deuxième tour
contre un adversaire et donc tout le
monde n'a pas voté pour son programme
sens de vous avez raison de ce point de
vue là moi j'ai jamais pensé qu'une
élection c'était l'adoption d'un
programme une élection c'est le choix
d'un président le choix d'un président
en lui-même est le choix d'un président
contre les autres et donc de ce point de
vue là
le moment que nous vivons c'est le
moment où il faut précisément que soit
pris en compte ces deux aspects des
choses le premier c'est il y a un
problème de morale il y a un problème de
démoralisation du pays à tort ou à
raison et deuxièmement il y a des sujets
à traiter qu'on peut pas laisser sur le
bordel là mais ça veut dire qu'il va pas
parler de la réforme des retraites ce
soir je pense que si honnête au terme
d'une d'une séquence
et j'imagine en tout cas ça me
paraîtrait naturel
qu'il tire les leçons de cette séquence
qu'il
rendent aux Français qui rendent compte
aux Français des choix qui ont été faits
et qui sont si importants pour leur
avenir vous savez ce que je ce que
j'affirme
on n'a pas réussi à transmettre
l'explication fondamentale de la réforme
des retraites et cette explication
fondamentale est une explication qui
repose sur une injustice qu'on accepte
depuis trop longtemps c'est que les
pensions des retraités d'aujourd'hui
sont payés avec de la dette on n'a pas
réussi à expliquer la réforme on a aussi
promulgué la réforme de la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel je vais vous
répondre berger
la phrase que j'ai dit en considérant
que bon fallait aller à l'autre sujet
mais excusez-moi un pays qui accepte que
la pension
mensuelle tous les mois des retraités
soit payé en empruntant l'argent qui
devra être remboursé par les plus jeunes
mais ce pays-là il est en
faute morale
c'est c'est inacceptable mais c'est pas
forcément ce qu'on dit les manifestants
les manifestants pour certains d'entre
eux ils ont dit comme vous ils ont dit
une autre réforme oui il faut réformer
il fallait réformer mais une autre
réforme était possible vous avez plaidé
vous-même notre référence l'ombre à
faire sur les retraites pour qu'on
augmente les cotisations patronales pour
arriver justement à l'équipe vous n'avez
pas été entendu donc finalement vous
dites qu'une partie des manifestations
de rappeler
mais une autre réforme était possible
oui puisqu'on l'avait adopté on avait
adopté la réforme par point la retraite
par point elle avait été adoptée y
compris à l'Assemblée nationale et puis
on a décidé il a été décidé qu'on change
les cotisations patronales la
contestation n'aurait peut-être pas été
la
je veux bien vous dire ce que je
proposais
je proposais qu'on prenne en compte
cette réalité insupportable que c'est
pas possible de faire payer par de la
dette qui sera remboursé par les plus
jeunes les pensions des retraités
actuels et ça depuis 20 ans ça fait des
centaines de milliards d'euros
et donc et je proposais qu'en effet on
choisisse sur dix ans ou sur 12 ans un
retour à l'équilibre qui serait prise en
charge à la fois par l'allongement de la
durée du travail et par la contribution
par d'autres contributions
si on va au plein emploi ça va faire
rentrer beaucoup d'argent dans les
caisses si on améliore la productivité
du pays ça va faire entrer beaucoup
d'argent dans les caisses et il me
paraissait en effet juste que par
exemple il y ait une légère augmentation
de la cotisation des entreprises et même
mes amis à l'Assemblée nationale avait
proposé qu'il y ait une contribution des
des plus-values des gains quand vous
avez proposé ça à Emmanuel Macron avec
quel argument vous a-t-il répondu non
parce que le Président de la République
et le gouvernement sont très soucieux de
l'attractivité de la France
vous avez vu qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
progrès ces dernières années tout d'un
coup la France qui était un pays rejeté
par les investisseurs internationaux
tout d'un coup est devenu attrayant mais
vous allez convaincu par cet argument
très soucieux
moi je suis un peu têtu vous savez trop
trop je reconnais que que cette
obstination est naturellement
répréhensible mais non je continue à
penser que
le jour où on posera réellement la
question du retour à l'équilibre
pas celle qui a été traitée dans cette
réforme là qui est simplement éviter une
augmentation du déséquilibre et des
déficits nouveaux mais le jour où on
posera la question du retour à
l'équilibre alors il faudra un mixte de
contribution
ne serait-ce que pour que
l'idée de justice soit prise en compte
donc si je résume en disant que cette
réforme n'est pas tout à fait la vôtre
oui
j'ai pas entièrement tort non vous avez
entièrement raison et quand vous
regardez le bilan économique de cette
réforme qui qui veut économiser 10
milliards d'économies par an mais en se
fâchant avec tous les syndicats toute
l'opposition est-ce que vous dites ça
emballer la peine dans le la question de
ce fâcher est une présentation
pardonnez-moi prenez pas mal ce que je
vais dire de cours de récréation les
syndicats les organisations
professionnelles
ont l'habitude du rapport de force et
c'est leur leur langue maternelle et
donc oui il y a des rapports de force
oui il y a des désaccords
c'est des accords
devront être réduits j'allais dire
aurait pu être réduit je suis je suis
persuadé que que le chemin existe
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous avez lu
les déclarations de Laurent Berger dans
Le Parisien hier son interview bah il
ouvre la porte à des rapprochements
après le premier mai le premier mai
c'est dans 15 jours on peut pas dire que
qui est aucun chemin imaginable de
rencontre et de travail en commun et
permettez-moi de vous faire observer une
chose dont on parlait juste avant
c'était juste avant qu'on vienne sur le
plateau
les gens enfin un certain nombre
d'observateurs disent aujourd'hui
les décisions prises par le Conseil
constitutionnel ont annulé des
dispositions qui étaient très positives
on va en parler ça prouve qu'il y avait
des dispositions positives dans le texte
on va en parler ça prouve que en réalité
la présentation caricaturale ou enfin
polémique je veux pas dire caricatural
qui était faite des choses elle
correspondait pas à la réalité il y a
moins négatives aussi
dans le texte je voudrais en dire une
phrase donc personne ne parle et que je
trouvais extrêmement positif c'est la
retraite progressive
à partir le texte ouvre la possibilité à
partir de 62 ans que vous répartissez
votre temps entre le travail et le début
de la retraite en touchant une
compensation qui est une partie de la
retraite
ça c'est un sujet sur lequel pour ma
part en tout cas je m'étais battu depuis
longtemps moi aussi pardon je vais être
mis à la retraite progressive si je
lance pas le fil info à 8h43 et on vous
retrouve dans un instantané de faire
chier
l'incendie est désormais sous contrôle
mais reste sous les surveillance des
pompiers indique sur France Info la
présidente du département des
Pyrénées-Orientales on est dans un
moment inédit ajouté avec aussi la
sécheresse en avril dans le secteur de
Cerbère et de Banyuls 930 hectares de
végétation ont été parcourus par les
flammes l'apaisement objectif de
l'exécutif Emmanuel Macron s'adresse aux
Français ce soir à locution à 20h après
la promulgation vendredi de la loi de
réforme sur les retraites les syndicats
eux se réunissent à 19h il n'y a pas de
fissure au sein de l'Inter syndicale
mais une exigence de rigueur collective
indique ce matin le secrétaire général
de la CFDT Laurent Berger quelle est la
responsabilité d'Airbus c'est celle
d'Air France dans l'accident du Rio
Paris la justice rend sa décision en
début d'après-midi 14 ans après le drame
qui a fait 228 morts en décembre dernier
le procureur à Reiki la relax la Chine
dit maintenir un haut niveau d'alerte
face à la présence d'un destroyer
américain dans le détroit de Taïwan des
trois revendiquées par Pékin il y a une
semaine le pouvoir chinois a mener dans
cette zone des exercices militaires de
grande ampleur
France Info
le 8 30 France Info Samia brachia Marc
Fauvel François
plus dure de la réforme des retraites
qui est sorti du Conseil constitutionnel
le repas
finir le report de l'âge légal à 64 ans
lui a été validé mais les 6 points
censurés sont des mesures sociales comme
le CDI senior ou l'index senior est-ce
qu'il va falloir améliorer cette loi
ajouter d'autres dispositions dans de
nouveaux textes
l'index senior c'était une incitation
c'est un moyen d'incitation justifier
bon le Conseil constitutionnel conclu
qu'il fallait pas faire chevaucher des
mesures budgétaires avec des mesures qui
ne l'était pas et bien il faut le
reprendre
tout ce qui est de l'ordre de l'entente
avec les organisations de salariés avec
des organisations patronales sur
lesquelles un accord avait été trouvé
dans ce texte avec l'Assemblée le Sénat
il faut les reprendre est-ce qu'il faut
reprendre aussi vos mesures
comme on dit notre projet notre texte
qui permettra de traiter ces questions
et il faut le faire de manière détendue
vous voyez bien que le ciel ne s'est pas
écroulé sur la terre au moment de la
décision du Conseil
constitutions patronales ou pas non je
pense que comme je vous l'ai dit c'est
un projet d'ensemble si on décide un
jour et je suis persuadé qu'un jour
cette question se posera
d'aller vers l'équilibre de nos finances
publiques nous ne pouvons pas rester
durablement le pays le plus endetté de
toute l'Europe alors c'est un sujet que
vous savez j'ai traité dans la
République française depuis
15 ans et et je crois que c'est un sujet
de souveraineté c'est un vous n'êtes pas
libre si vous êtes endetté et
et c'est une démarche de de père de
famille et de citoyens que de dire on va
recouvrer cette liberté dans le livre du
journaliste de l'opinion Ludovic Vigan
qui vient de paraître
on apprend qu'il vous est arrivé de vous
faire rabrouer on va dire ça comme ça
par Emmanuel Macron au sujet justement
de la réforme des retraites je cite ce
qui Emmanuel Macron vous a dit écoute
François qui visiblement lui vous tutoie
bon il y a ceux qui ont été candidats
trois fois vous et il y a ceux qui ont
été élus deux fois lui c'est moi qui
rajoute le moi et le lui comment ça
s'appelle ça c'était sur c'est un
échange
je trouve que nous avons des relations
assez libres et la célébrons est assez
direct avec le président de la
République et heureusement parce
qu'autrement à quoi ça servirait mais
vous a bien dit ça et donc il m'a dit
l'esprit était celui-là et c'était sur
deux sujets sur la retraite à 65 ans et
je défendais la retraite à 64 ans
puisqu'il y avait eu un vote du donc
vous avez gagné là-dessus et deuxième
sujet je pensais qu'il fallait prendre
quatre mois je disais à l'époque pour
qu'on puisse
améliorer approfondir et faire la
pédagogie de la réforme ces quatre mois
ont été accordés donc de ce point de
vue-là
les données des conseils à celui qui l'a
gagné deux fois oui vous savez
l'expérience
dans les temps difficiles c'est quelque
chose qui pèse lourd je dis toujours
vous voulez traverser l'Atlantique avec
votre famille et les temps et la météo
est pas très bonne est-ce que vous
choisissez un skipper très expérimenté
ou un skipper qui pour la première fois
va essayer son nouveau bateau je n'ai
aucun doute que l'expérience au moins
certaines époques dans la vie d'un pays
est positive les Français parlent
beaucoup des retraites ils parlent aussi
parce qu'il la tous les jours de
l'inflation est-ce qu'il faut un geste
aujourd'hui François Bayrou un geste
fiscal ou un geste d'un geste d'une
autre nature pour les aider alors on a
trouvé heureusement un certain nombre de
choses à faire sur le prix sur des
campagnes de prix protégés dans les
grandes surfaces et tout ça et tout ça
est extrêmement positif mais
l'idée qu'il existe quelque part un
trésor dans lequel on va pouvoir aller
puiser pour distribuer de l'argent sur
tous les sujets avec des chèques sur
tous les sujets cette idée est une
tromperie ceci Emmanuel Macron avait
promis par exemple que que les couples
non mariés les couples en concubinage
pardon pouvait à un moment déclarer
ensemble leurs impôts allez-vous
qu'est-ce qu'elle est devenue cette
promesse bon je pense que tout ça est
plutôt dans la bonne voie et plutôt en
cours c'est pas dans le prochain
c'est plus dans les tuyaux aujourd'hui
les groupes parlementaires sont là pour
relayer des attentes du pays sur des
sujets comme ça qui sont des sujets
importants mais mais marginaux mais le
trésor existe bien sûr
il suffit de perpétuellement emprunter
des centaines de milliards et on fait
comme si notre pays pouvait sans cesse
distribuer de de nouveaux avantages de
nouvelles allocations ça n'est pas vrai
la chose la plus importante c'est que ce
pays retrouve sa dynamique notre pays
retrouve sa dynamique pour créer des
richesses créer des emplois inventés et
permettre de répondre à tous ces
problèmes si angoissants qui pèsent sur
nous le problème climatique le problème
de l'épuisement ou en tout cas de
de la distance prise avec le travail et
le problème de l'éducation voilà au
moins trois sujets majeurs et qui va
falloir reprendre je vais tenter de
regagner des points retraite 8h50 le fil
info vient de faire cheat et on poursuit
dans un instant avec vous François
Bayrou au commissaire au Plan président
du MoDem et maire de Pau invité de
France Info
les surgelés les produits du rayon frais
mais aussi des aliments pour animaux en
tête des produits du quotidien qui
augmente le plus sur un en 18% de hausse
notamment pour les croquettes pour les
chiens et les chats enseignement du
panier France Info dans l'ensemble ces
13% plus cher au moment de régler ses
achats le feu maîtriser mais pas encore
fixé dans les Pyrénées-Orientales il a
parcouru plus de 900 hectares dans le
secteur de Cerbère et de Banyuls avant
de franchir la frontière avec l'Espagne
première incendie de cette ampleur pour
cette année en France 500
sapeurs-pompiers mobilisés la saison des
feux ne sait jamais arrêté alerte la
Fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers de France Emmanuel
Macron espère passer à autre chose il
s'adresse aux Français ce soir après
avoir promulgué la loi de réforme des
retraites ce week-end édition spéciale
sur France Info des 19h30 et puis l'OM
Renaud avec la victoire à domicile en
battant trois hier soir victoire trois
buts à un des Marseillais qui récupère
la deuxième place du classement de Ligue
1 en tête le PSG qui s'est encore
rapproché un peu plus ce weekend à 11e
titre de champion de France
[Musique]
France Info
le 8 30 France Info Samia brachiha Mark
forêt toujours avec François Barroux
question à l'ancien ministre de
l'Éducation la réforme du bac la réforme
blanquette fait qu'aujourd'hui les
lycéens terminal savent quasiment tous
alors que nous sommes à la mi-avril
s'ils vont décrocher le bac à la fin de
la saison parce qu'ils ont les résultats
des épreuves de spécialité et parce que
le bac se fait désormais en partie en
contrôle continu du coup le grand oral
et l'épreuve de philo qui arrivent au
mois de juin compte quasiment pour du
beurre est-ce que c'était une bonne idée
la réforme du bac je l'ai dit à
Jean-Michel Blanquer
a apporté
[Musique]
beaucoup de complexité
dans l'idée que les élèves et leurs
familles se font des études secondaires
et comme vous le dites ça a des
conséquences de très long terme ça
beaucoup de conséquences il y a une de
ces conséquences dont on ne parle jamais
c'est que le groupe classe on a tous
vécu des classes on a été dans des
classes on a des amis de classe des
copains de classe le groupe classe
n'existe presque plus parce qu'il a
éclaté en option en dizaines d'options
en tout cas un très grand nombre
d'options ce qui rend pour les chefs
d'établissement impossible
l'établissement des des emplois du temps
et ce qui fait exploser ce groupe amical
qui comptait tant pour la formation
personnelle pour pour son pour son
éducation sociale vous pensez qu'il faut
réformer la réforme je suis persuadé
qu'un jour cette question se reposera et
devra être reposée ne serait-ce comme
vous le dites parce qu'il y a des
chaises vides dans les classes et parce
que on me dit en tout cas que
la philo n'a plus d'importance ou n'a
plus l'importance qu'elle devrait avoir
cette discipline qui consiste autant que
possible à apprendre à penser
se trouve aujourd'hui un peu marginalisé
et je trouve que cette dommage et que
donc
le fond de ce que je pense et que
l'équilibre des trois années
d'enseignement secondaire d'enseignement
du lycée
n'est pas satisfaisant aujourd'hui de
même que parcours sub me paraît pas
totalement satisfaisant mais peut-être
comme vous le dites ce sont des ce sont
des nostalgies de ministres de
l'Éducation nationale j'ai pas dit ça
moi ni question ministres
de fissurer davantage un peu un peu plus
la société il concerne la fin de vie
Emmanuel Macron veut loi cet été vous à
la question faut-il changer la loi
c'est la question qu'on vous a posé
quand vous êtes venu la première fois
c'était pas la dernière fois pardon
c'était il y a deux ans le 8 avril 2021
précisément quand on vous a posé la
question faut-il changer la loi vous
nous avez répondu appliquons-la d'abord
cette loi a été votée à la lune à
l'unanimité de l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce que disent les auteurs c'est
qu'elle n'est pas appliquée comme elle
devait l'être là aussi sur la question
de la fin de vie il y a des accords avec
Emmanuel Macron et bien vous voyez ma
réponse n'a pas changé sur ce sujet donc
j'ai passé des dizaines d'heures ces
derniers mois avec
les soignants
qui s'occupent des malades en fin de vie
avec les soignants des soins palliatifs
tous
les médecins
les infirmiers infirmières
les aides soignants
jusqu'aux personnes qui s'occupent des
repas
et j'ai passé beaucoup d'heures avec eux
d'abord je trouve que leur vocation
est admirable
je trouve que ceux qui justifient leur
vie en donnant leur
affection leur présence au dernier
moment de leur
enfin des personnes qui sont à leur
charge des patients qui sont à leur
charge je trouve que c'est admirable
comme vocation aucun
Nadi il faut changer la loi au contraire
tous disent si on nous oblige
à donner la mort au lieu de défendre la
vie en partie ré il y a pas construits
non oui vous avez tout à fait raison on
en a pas le texte
tout ça va tout ça va être mais il faut
pas une nouvelle loi
je pense que la réponse que je vous ai
faite il y a deux ans est juste
appliquons la loi qui n'est pas
appliquée aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a
des dizaines de départements qui n'ont
pas d'organisation de soins palliatifs
il y a à construire y compris dans les
dans beaucoup d'hôpitaux
ce service
ultime est profondément humaniste qui
consiste à être là quand la femme ou
l'homme qui vous est confiée va passer
de l'autre côté mais vous imaginez
François Bayrou Emmanuel Macron allait
contre les conclusions de la convention
citoyenne qui l'a lui-même chargé de
réfléchir à cette question c'est pas si
c'est à les contre je sais pas si vous
avez lu les contribution
elle dit à la majorité c'est-à-dire
selon une procédure de vote mais comme
les comme moi je ne connais pas les les
femmes et les hommes qui faisaient
partie de la convention citoyenne c'est
pas le vote qui est la bonne qui est la
bonne démarche la bonne démarche quand
vous avez une convention citoyenne qui
est formée si j'ai bien compris partir à
au sort d'une certaine partie la bonne
démarche c'est d'écouter leurs arguments
et de voir leur maturation et nombre
d'entre eux ont défendu une autre
position maintenant c'est le Parlement
la majorité donne le donne la voix à au
suicide assister
on traitera de cette question une autre
fois
vous avez une convention citoyenne qui
est formée aléatoirement ça n'est pas
une démocratie représentative c'est une
démocratie de participation donc le vote
qui décide des conclusions n'engage pas
le reste de la société
de la convention citoyenne pour pouvoir
prendre sa décision son intuition c'est
de s'appuyer sur cette convention il
pense qu'il y a là une démarche nouvelle
de d'élaborer une réflexion de la
société mais moi je dis que l'Assemblée
nationale le Sénat ne sont pas engagés
et en tout cas les consciences ne sont
pas engagées j'ai dit au député au
sénateur de notre de la famille
politique que je que je préside j'ai dit
liberté de conscience chacun d'entre
vous
il n'y a pas d'engagement de parties sur
une affaire comme celle-là c'est un
homme et une femme dans le plus secret
de ce qu'il a qui va décider de
quelle est son orientation et mon
orientation à moi c'est d'aider
ceux qui apporte ce cet ultime
affections approfondir et appliqués la
loi parce qu'elle n'est pas appliquée
merci François Bayrou président du MoDem
était ce matin l'invité de France Info
bonne journée à vous
[Musique]